brilliant
good afternoon and welcome to modifield
my name is Kirsten Oswald and I am the
SNP business convener and I'm delighted
to be here today at the culmination of
this election contest to choose our new
SNP leader
the contest has taken our three
candidates the length and breadth of
Scotland they've beamed into our living
rooms we have TV debates and they've
worked tirelessly to engage with members
all over the country
so this is a historic moment for the SNP
and as we look forward to our new leader
I want to thank Nicholas sturgeon for
her exceptional leadership over the past
eight and a half years
I'd also like to convey my thanks to the
candidates to our members and to
everyone at snphq and our national
executive committee who've worked so
hard behind the scenes to deliver this
important exercise in party democracy
and I'm delighted to Welcome to the
stage to announce a review leader Lorna
Finn SNP National secretary
as National Secretary of the SNP I have
been given the results of the party
leader election 2023 from my voice the
ballot Services Company
these are as follows
the final number of eligible members was
72 169.
a total of 50
494 ballot papers containing a valid
vote were received there were three
rejected postal ballot papers the
turnout was therefore 70 percent
645 of the ballots were cast
electronically and
1849 of the ballots were cast by post
the first preference votes are as
follows
ashwagen
5599 this represents 11.1 percent of
first preference votes
Kate Forbes 20
559 this represents 48.7 of the first
preference votes
Hamza Yusuf 24
336 this represents 48.2 percent of the
first preference votes
as no candidate received more than 50
percent of the votes Ash Reagan as the
candidate who received the least number
of First preferences was eliminated and
the second preference votes in favor of
Cape Forbes or Hamza Yusuf were given to
them
the result after those votes were
redistributed was as follows
Kate Forbes 23
890 this represents 47.9 of the final
vote
Hamza Yusuf 26 000 and 32 this
represents 52.1 final votes
I therefore declare Hamza Yusuf Julie
elected as the Scottish national party
leader
congratulations
thank you
foreign
National secretary Lorna Finn and also
can I thank our headquarters staff for
all the incredible efforts that they
have made right throughout this process
it is hard for me to find the words to
describe just how honored I am to be
entrusted by our membership of the SNP
to be the parties next leader and to be
on the cusp of being our country's next
first minister
can I begin by paying tribute to my
colleagues both Kate and Ash during
almost 20 hostings it's probably fell
like we've seen each other more than we
have our respective families you both
have put in an incredible shift and I
know that collectively we will continue
to work hard as part of Team SNP
uh I am not just humbled of that I most
certainly am I also feel like the
luckiest man in the world to be standing
here as a leader of the SNP a party I
joined almost 20 years ago and that I
love so dearly
friends it was the late John Smith and
he got it absolutely right when he said
the opportunity to serve our country is
all we ask
to serve my country as first Minister
will be the greatest privilege and honor
of my life should Parliament decide to
elect me as Scotland's next first
Minister tomorrow
and just as I will lead the SNP in the
interests of all party members
not just those who voted for me so I
will aim to lead Scotland in the
interests of all of our citizens
whatever your political allegiance if
elected as your first Minister after
tomorrow's vote in Parliament know that
I will be a first Minister for all of
Scotland that I will work every minute
of every day to earn and to re-air your
respect and your trust
I will do that by treating you the
people of Scotland with respect
there will be no empty promises or easy
sound bites when the issues in front of
us are difficult and complex because
government is not easy and I won't
pretend that it is
my immediate priority will be to
continue to protect every score as far
as we possibly can from the harm
inflicted by the cost of living crisis
to recover and reform our NHS and other
vital public services to support our
well-being economy to improve the life
chances of people right across this
country I will move quickly to develop
plans to extend child care to improve
rural housing support small businesses
and boost Innovation I will bring
forward reforms of the Criminal Justice
System our work with local government to
empower our local authorities
and as first Minister I will not shy
away from those exceptionally tough
challenges that require the difficult
decisions
but with this challenge I will use it to
also find opportunity
my government will seize the economic
and social opportunity that the journey
to Net Zero will bring a country is
energy rich as Scotland should not have
people living in fuel poverty the
government I lead will renew and
redouble our efforts to lift people out
of poverty to make work fair to make our
economy work for the people and to
ensure as we become a more prosperous
country we also become a fairer country
too
and while I have had my fair share of
battles with the UK government over the
years and there may well be some to come
I will work with them and other devolved
Nations constructively where I can in
the best interests of our nation
I'm a pro Scot an equally a proud
European too and Scotland is a European
nation we want to return to the European
Union and play our part in building a
continent that's based on human rights
and peace prosperity and social justice
to the people of Scotland the SNP has
earned your trust by governing well
by ensuring that your priorities are our
priorities
as a party and as a government we are at
our best when we are radical and Bold
and the challenges we face today they
require nothing less of us
that is what I promised the people of
Scotland if parliament of course puts
its trust in me tomorrow
joining the SNP for me was an act of
Hope but it was also a statement of
intent I was determined then as I am now
that we will deliver Independence for
Scotland
together
as a team
leadership elections by their very
nature can be bruising however in SNP we
are a family over the last five weeks we
may have been competitors or supporters
of different candidates we are no longer
team Hamza or team Ash or team Kate we
are one team and we will be the team we
will be the generation that delivers
Independence for Scotland
where there are divisions to heal we
must do so quickly because we have a job
to do as a party we are at our strongest
when we are united and what unites us is
our shared goal of delivering
Independence for our nation
to those in Scotland who don't yet quite
share that passion that I do for
Independence I will aim to earn your
trust by continuing to ensure we govern
well and earn your respect as first
Minister by focusing on the priorities
that matter to all of us and in doing so
using our devolved powers to the
absolute maximum effect to tackle the
challenges of the day
and for those of us in this room and
watching who do believe in Independence
we will only win by making that case on
the doorsteps and my solemn promise and
commitment to you is that I will
kick-start our Grassroots our Civic LED
movement and ensure a drive for
Independence is in fifth gear the people
of Scotland need Independence now more
than ever before and we will be the
generation that delivers Independence
for Scotland
before concluding
I want to take the opportunity to thank
some very very special people indeed and
I wouldn't be standing here today if it
wasn't for the support and the
encouragement of a number of
hard-working people
first of all there is my amazing wife
Nadia she is not just my rock she is my
compass who helps to guide me through
the most difficult times in life there
but there is no way not a chance in hell
that I would be standing here if it was
not for your love for your support and
for your advice thank you for believing
me and for always being there for me I
will love you more and I do love you
more than words uh more than the words
that I can find to express to my girls
this job will at times be all-consuming
I suspect but know that there is no more
important job in my life than being your
dad uh to Maya and Mao you will always
always come first
so my mum to my dad to my sisters
thank you for your unwavering support
throughout my life for picking me up
when I have been down and for telling me
to keep going when at times I had my
doubts I'd also like to thank my
phenomenal campaign team you have worked
day and night over the last few weeks to
support me you've all sacrificed time
with your family and your friends
because like me you believe in our
vision of a progressively Progressive
socially just Scotland and I will not
let you down a special mention to Neil
gray he is quite simply the best corner
man I could have asked for during the
roller coaster of emotion that is any
leadership contest you have been by my
side and there's no way I would admit it
to the Finish Line without your support
and to my good friend and colleague
Shawna Robinson your wise counsel has
been indispensable to me doing this
contest
to our now former leader Nicola sturgeon
and her Deputy in government John
Swinney thank you for your dedicated
service to this party to our country and
to all the people of Scotland you have
left me strong foundations to build upon
and thank you to my colleagues and both
parliaments across local government and
activists around the country who have
been so supportive and so encouraging I
will share that I have and I will ensure
that I harness all of the talent across
the party and across the country as I
build that team that will take Scotland
forward to deliver our nation's
independence from our brilliant MPS led
abley by Stephen Flynn and by Mary Black
in Westminster to our leaders in local
government as well as our exceptional
group of msps in the Scottish Parliament
our Parliament has an array of talent
right through its ranks our
parliamentarians our councilors our
activists our members all have a vital
part to play on our journey to
Independence as there are friends right
across the independence movement to have
your confidence as I take on the role as
SNP leader means so much to me
my final thanks is to my grandparents
unfortunately they're no longer alive to
see this dude but I'm forever forever
thankful
that my grandparents made the trip from
Punjab to Scotland over 60 years ago
as immigrants to this country who knew
barely a word of English they could not
have imagined and their wildest dreams
that their grandson would one day be on
the cusp of being the next first
minister of Scotland
as Muhammad Yusuf walked in the Singer
sewing machine factory in clydebank
as ramad Ali Buddha stamped tickets from
the Glasgow Corporation buses
they could not have imagined as I say in
the wildest dreams that two generations
later that their grandson would one day
be on the cusp of being Scotland's first
Minister we should all take pride in the
fact that today we have sent a clear
message that your color of skin or
indeed your faith is not a barrier to
Leading the country that we all call
home
from the Punjab to our Parliament this
is a journey over Generations that
reminds us we should be celebrating and
always celebrate the migrants who
contribute so much to our country
this is what drives my commitment to
equality that will underpinned my
actions as first minister
thank you for the honor of choosing me
to be your nominee to become to become
Scotland's sixth first minister
I will dedicate every waking moment to
serving you
the people of Scotland thank you very
much
thank you
thank you very much I think we are going
to take some questions from the Press I
think there was a list that was given to
me and we'll come to that right there we
go we want to take some questions here
uh for the best uh BBC James Cook
thanks very much indeed congratulations
on the historic nature of your election
victory
was suggested during this campaign that
it will be difficult to fill the shoes
of Nicholas sturgeon as a politician of
considerable stature and yet on the
central defining mission of your party
Independence ultimately she failed what
makes you think you can succeed where
she couldn't
so first and foremost I want to pitch up
you again to Nicholas sturgeon because
she has left us with a really strong
foundation and people build upon that
Foundation I will build upon that
Foundation but it won't just be me I'm
going to build the team that's going to
deliver Independence I've already spoken
throughout this campaign of how much
admiration I have for both the
colleagues who join me in this
leadership contest that have also spoken
about the array of talent in the
parliament's Scottish Westminster
Parliament across local government that
will help to build that team that
delivers Independence so it's thanks to
Nicholas thurton it's thanks to John
Swinney it's thanks to those strong
foundations that they left us that we
will go on to finish the job thanks
James uh call Makai
congratulations this has been a bruising
contest for your party the result shows
just how divided it is how do you start
by uniting your party and then regaining
the trust of the people of Scotland in a
Scottish government
well first and foremost after I've
spoken to the media one of the first
meetings I expect to have and would like
to have it would be with Kate and Ash
because it is important that the party
comes together I try to stress that my
opening and my remarks that we are at
our strongest as a party when we are
united and what unites us is the goal of
delivering Independence for Scotland so
of course election contests by that
nature can be challenging they can't
open up some divisions but I've got no
doubt not just faith and myself but I
have absolute faith that my colleagues
Ash and in Kate that we will come
together and there will be no team Hamza
there will be no team Kate there will be
no team Ash there will be team SNP and
it will be team SMP that will deliver
Independence for our country
congratulations
um does this outcome tell you that
obviously a lot of people wanted your
opponent to and almost 48 of them
offering are quite a different approach
and you were the continuity candidate in
this election does this result tell you
that continuity won't cut it
well I'm delighted to be standing here
as the person that the majority of
membership have put their faith in but
what I will do is of course reach across
the divides that may well exist I've
always said as much as I admire and
respect Nicola and I really do I will be
my own man I will be I will do
leadership my own way and one of those
ways will be to have as big a tin as
possible and that includes of course the
various different uh the various
different platforms that have been put
forward by my colleagues I want to speak
to them as soon as I'm finished speaking
to you because we have to harness not
just the talent but the idea is that my
colleagues have brought forward so as
I've said the other colleagues who've
already asked questions I don't view
this as there being factions or teams
there's going to be one team that's
going to deliver us independence in
terms of the government we are still of
course uh the party that is more trusted
than any other political party in
Scotland I'll not take that for granted
I'll not be complacent about that but we
have won the trusted people of Scotland
because we have delivered for them and
that my to continue to deliver for the
people of Scotland
just behind you
uh congratulations uh first of all
um the polls were suggesting throughout
the contest that you of the three
candidates were the most incompetent
weak and untrustworthy how are you going
to turn that around and not fail on the
S P's election wedding machine that it
has been over the course of the last few
years well I'm delighted to be part of
that election running machine and being
part of government for 10 and a half
years but on top of that of course I'm
delighted that when I've stood for
election I've been elected and
re-elected with a big majority from the
people of Glasgow Pollock who I'd like
to thank him putting their trust in me
uh over the years but what I'll make
sure I do is I govern and govern what in
the interest of the people of Scotland
but also we win the trust of the people
of Scotland when we govern uh and we
aligned with their priorities their
priorities have to be our priorities and
of course they will look to us at Ford
delivery and I will do my best to
deliver what is their priorities and at
the moment I don't have to tell anybody
in this room that people are suffering
from a cost of living crisis that'll be
my first intermediate priority to try to
help them in that regard so I've got
every confidence not just my own ability
but frankly the ability of the
exceptional samp team that exists not
just in the Scottish Parliament as good
and exceptional as my MSP colleagues are
but right across the parliaments and
local government and our active activist
based through
uh Glen Campbell
congratulations uh on being elected how
can you possibly hope to unite the
country if you're still going to be
pushing hard for Independence one
dependence for me is a golden thread
that runs through so many of our
priority and policy areas the reason why
we can only mitigate the cost of living
crisis is because it's a crisis that's
inflicted by Westminster we're doing so
with one hand tied behind our backs the
reason that why we can only invest in
our Public Services as much as we can is
because again our budget our fixed
budget is controlled by a Westminster
government so why we will deliver the
priorities of the people of Scotland
that will be to tackle the cost of
living crisis that will be to continue
to invest in our public services our NHS
of course in particular it will be to
make progress on our well-being economy
that does not we will do that in tandem
with making the case for Independence
because Independence will unleash our
country's true potential
Craig
to you hello ah there we go
um the tournament in this election was
only 70 so 30 of SMP members didn't even
see fit to vote what are you going to do
to engage them and is there a worry at
all that membership numbers could sink
even further
no we'll be aiming to to hopefully grow
those membership numbers and I hope
people are inspired not just by the
contest and hopefully by the outcome as
well I hope people will join the SNP as
the vehicle that will deliver
Independence for Scotland in terms of
the 70 percent I think it's so important
for not just me but the team the SNP
team to make sure we are putting the
independent drive into fifth gear our
members are inspired and they'll be
inspired undoubtedly by the drive to
Independence we inspire people not by
getting stuck in a quagmire of process
and talking about section 30s and de
facto referendums they get inspired by
talking about policy and I've got I hope
the skills and the ability to be able to
inspire people with a vision for
Independence I believe that will help us
to increase our membership numbers but
also make sure all of our members are
involved in that campaign
I think we have um strip cream from ESP
I think we've got some International
media there's a microphone coming to you
excellent I was just wondering uh with
Independence do you have a timeline of
when you'd like to see that happen and
um how would you convince those uh you
seems to be stuck on 45 they're simply
the same figures in 2014. uh many people
I speak to are not convinced about the
economic plan the s p has how are you
going to reassure those people and make
them feel comfort that it's in their
interest to vote for Independence yeah
that's a good question so our colleagues
in the Scottish media have been asking
me this for five weeks uh time and I'll
give them give you the same answer that
I give them which is of course a process
while it is important the key to getting
Independence is ensuring we have that
consistent majority support for
Independence we had that settled well
for Independence if we have that the
political obstacles that I put in our
that are put in our way by Westminster
well they will disappear so the
concentration will be on kickstarting
that Civic LED Grassroots people-led
movement and growing consistency or from
dependency of course the economic plan
is absolutely key to that so we have of
course published papers already on that
but I think we've got uh more work
absolutely to do to convince people we
wouldn't be standing here if that wasn't
the case so one of the first things I'll
get on with doing as well as governing
and delivering and governing well I hope
it will also be to make sure we
Kickstart that Independence Movement
um Maria or Maria forgive me from alzina
nope
okay
um we've got Alan Smith from Borough
congratulations in response to the
question from Colin you said in terms of
uniting the party speaking with both
Kate and Ash does that mean there'll be
room around your cabinet table for both
of your leadership Rivals and and just
secondly
um in terms of the vote just over 26 000
first and second preference votes means
you become SMP leader ultimately
becoming first Minister what do you see
then in response to opposition parties
who who will claim that you have nomadic
to govern and perhaps there should be an
election
so um look I I salute the fact that
you've been asking me for weeks now uh
Alan for exclusive uh on my cabinet uh
that is something of course that I'll be
giving consideration to and announcing
uh in due course but I've never shied
away from seeing both Kate and Ash uh
not just exceptional talents within our
party but have clearly got a role to
play a continued role in Scottish public
life in terms of the Mandate that of
course Parliament will have it say uh
tomorrow although I am party leader at
the moment there will be a vote and
there will be an opportunity for the
opposition uh to put their candidate
forward it is not by coincidence or
somehow good fortune that we are the
largest party in that Scottish
Parliament that is down to the fact that
the people of Scotland have given us
that mandate have put their trust in us
and tomorrow as I say I will be one of
the nominees certainly to be first
minister of Scotland and others will
have their chance to Jack from Global
radio
congratulations
um you take over leader of the SNP at a
time when there are a lot of question
marks over the parties finances that
have been renewed reports over the
weekend over
um accusations of quite murky Financial
dealings there what are you going to do
as leader to reassure the members of
your party but also the people in
Scotland who are concerned about that
and to to reassure them that this isn't
an issue well again uh I I suspect I'll
get up to speed very quickly on the
financial health of the party it's not
something I've obviously been involved
in not holding a an office better
position within the party but what I
would say is that a party will be
transparent in terms of the finances and
of course I couldn't comment on what is
a live investigation either but I
suspect it will be one of the very first
conversations I have as party leader to
understand uh the financial health of
the SNP
uh we'll go to some print colleagues as
well Paul at the Daily Record hi there
um you're going to lead a government
that is struggling on a range of fronts
um your party is under police
investigation over its finances and the
chief executive resigned after lies were
told about membership numbers so haven't
you got the worst job in Scottish
politics I've got the best job in
Scottish politics by far the honor and
the privilege of not just leading the
SNP but potentially being Scotland's
the next uh first Minister that I
inhered at a party that is the most
popular in Scotland by quite some
distance I uh and here at a party that
has the largest membership by quite some
considerable distance I have uh
converted a leader the government that
has a record of achievement that would
be the Envy of any other government not
just across these islands but in many
other parts of the world to other
challenges you betcha in government that
always are I've been in government for
10 and a half years I've never been in a
portfolio never seen a portfolio with
their own challenges but that is why we
step up we step up to lead and I hope by
governing well we will also lead people
to Independence uh the sun Rachel
thank you and I just on you have said
that you want to unite Scotland
um on this but then you in the hostings
you spoke a lot about independence
referendum you're asked questions about
five years for example with Scotland B
Independence within five years you said
you want to govern for all Scotland and
represent everyone no matter their
political beliefs and how do you square
that are you not just going to be as
divisive as Nicholas sturgeon felt she
was when she left well again Nicholas
dungeon enjoyed huge amounts of support
her leadership through the covert
pandemic in particular I saw so many
people who told me certainly on the
doorsteps that they wouldn't even have
been contemplated voting for The SNP but
it's a leadership that she she showed
during that period And so too must I and
the government that I lead we must show
leadership we must deliver for the
priorities of the people of Scotland
I've already outlined what I think those
priorities are if we do that then we win
the trust of people who win the trust of
people they will undoubtedly be
persuaded by our message on Independence
so we can do both we can both campaign
for Independence I don't think anybody
would expect the leader of the SNP to
see anything other than that but we can
also make sure that we deliver rightly
for the people of Scotland and their
priorities too
um we've got the national Abbey
hi there I'm hi congratulations and just
wanted to ask a quick couple of
questions so obviously everything goes
well tomorrow Hive over here obviously
everything goes well tomorrow you will
be first minister so what is the first
thing you're going to do to bring
Scotland closer to Independence and
obviously you've done an interview with
our newspaper during the campaign show
and you said that your cabinet which I
know you said you didn't want to give
away today that you would appoint a
minister for Independence so just
wondering if you had made any decisions
on that yeah well I will stick to those
commitments I made of course during the
campaign uh Trail for me one of the
first things I want to do is see how we
Kickstart that Civic LED campaign for
Independence it's got to be a Grassroots
lead it can't just be political leaders
uh sitting in a room devising strategies
on the way forward as important as the
leadership is uh of those who belong in
the independence movement has got to be
a Civic LED people-led movement that
drives forward the campaign for
Independence in terms of cabinet
Ministry appointments of course I'll
make them known uh energy course Daily
Mail Michael Blackley
hi hello in terms of two issues that
have divided the country you talk about
reaching out to non-ess voters
um two of the the key issues have been
the continued push for Independence
which you've talked quite substantially
about today uh will you continue to use
public money and the Civil Service time
drawing up the prospectus for
Independence and on the grr Bill uh will
you be challenging the UK government
section 35 order
so uh generally I think when a party
wins an election and as thoroughly as
the s p has has every right of course to
make sure it makes good on the Promises
in its Manifesto and we will do that and
of course at the Civil Service uh will
help us to deliver on all of our
Manifesto which includes of course uh
Independence we won the election quite
comprehensively uh in 2021 so just as uh
the UK government have the right to use
their civil service to pursue their
Ambitions around the Constitution it
should be no surprise that we will work
with the Civil Service to do the same
for Independence
um in terms of the grr Bill I've made my
position absolutely clear on Section 35
I see it as a as a veto as a paragraph
by the UK government I don't think they
have any right to have used that at
section 35 power given that the majority
of Hollywood of course backed the grr
bill so of course my first principle my
starting principal
um is to challenge that section five
order Peter will be moving very
patiently from ITV borders
there's a microphone coming to pizza
here or you can project if you wish
is that microphone coming
foreign
March campaigning you said we should
plant our flag in the ground right here
to let people know that they are not
forgotten people in the southwest and
south of Scotland and secondly we intend
to persuade every single person of the
merits of Independence that's why I want
to start the campaign for Independence
right here
so firstly how do you persuade people in
the south of Scotland they haven't been
forgotten and secondly when we be going
to Dumfries to launch your campaign very
soon very soon because I believe that
the only way we we went into our
independence and persuading those that
of course who voted no and are still not
persuaded by the case for Independence
and therefore we have to take the case
to not just a recent Galloway to the
borders to the South uh of Scotland and
we do that again by God's will we make
sure that there are opportunities for
people in the south of Scotland we make
sure we invest in the infrastructure in
the South uh off Scotland we make sure
we support the well-being economy of the
south of Scotland and we do that by
governing and governing well forgive me
I've just been told uh minutes ago that
I'm leader of the SNP I'll need to check
the diary but I'll be getting to them
free Shire as soon as I uh possibly can
I'll need to leave it there because
there are a range of other commitments
that I have to make I want to thank you
again to the leader to the members of
the SNP to our parliamentarians who are
seated here to our campaign team and
most importantly to my family for all
the support and all the encouragement
that they have given me we have a lot of
work to do and get on with so I suggest
we going with it thank you very much so
much